alors bonjour à la planète bonsoir à la
planète
bon après midi bonne matinée par tout
autre
et combien d'heures de différentes avec
la chine présentement au moins 12 16 dos
d'où l'étonnement vient csn
à l'opposé du canada se trouve la chine
si j'ai bien compris gm a ainsi enfreint
trou on n'a pas les plus au sud
oui on était jeunes nous situer pas je
vais pas gentil avoir causé un trou et
temps être dans la tendance et de
l'autre côté à la chine est exactement
alors bienvenue donc à tout le monde ici
qui est allé coûte malgré les matchs de
foot un peu partout dans le monde il ya
alice chantal tandem de la section
française qui est avec nous cette
semaine dont journalistes bonjour
stéphane de bonjour la planète c'est
gentil ça et puis léonie gimeno notre
webmestre qui fait le travail de deux
personnes notre autre ouais mais ce très
beau mariage en europe bonjour des eaux
alors écoutez on va parler de l'éléphant
sur le balcon avec nous comment ça se
passe du côté du match présentement à la
france et une serre au la france 1,5 à 3
minutes 26 secondes très bien car non
c'est pour vous rappeler que cette
émission est diffusée en direct si vous
regardez cette émission en différé bien
vous savez que déjà que la france gagne
et ce jusqu'à la dernière seconde
allez sans vous inviter parce que vous
allez très très importante à l'émission
aujourd'hui au mercy point important
parce que vous avez un fins palais oh
pas si sûr que ça des connaissances
géopolitique que tout à fait incroyable
tentaculaire non mais non et c'est lié à
notre sujet aujourd'hui de l'émission
vous êtes seul à pouvoir faire le jeu de
la devinette ans un climat cette semaine
puisque léo il dans le coup depuis lundi
y'a pas d'autres collègues sont tous
partis en vacances moi je sais rien vous
regardez les camps numéro 36 ans au
plafond et vous voyez la vidéo 5 images
vous me dites dès que vous pensez avoir
trouvé le sujet des missions premières
images
monsieur poutine zut et du maire prend
dutil sirop d'érable peut-être mais
c'est pas ça va
nous avons quelqu'un qui veut manger de
la poutine
peut-être numéro 3 je mets trois
ça ressemble à quoi 04/06 ça défile vite
quel est le sujet démission aujourd'hui
ses spécialités culinaires vraiment sur
de différents pays voici vous avez
raison la peine dans l'appareil et on va
vous aviez au restaurant tout de suite
après l'émission
vous irez tout seul je commence à me
lécher les babines
ouais je pense que c'est ce n'est qu'un
départ parce que on va donner des
recettes aujourd'hui on va parler donc
de du canada qui fait des canadiens qui
font tout un plat autour de la poutine
j'ai donc j'ai pensé à ça ce matin comme
ces démissions je sais je suis tombé en
plein dans la commune patate sûrement
petite question la routine c'est une
spécialité québécoise ou canadienne chez
les québécois ont une origine bien sûr
d'ailleurs ça nous mène à notre premier
jeu de la grosse boule de cette semaine
avant d'aller vers un invité spécial qui
se trouve sur skype qui est un expert de
la poutine voici vrai ou faux il ya
trois jeux dans l'émission vous le savez
vous connaissez règlement maintenant
premier jeu vous pour 20 points
et voici la question est la suivante
l'invention de la poutine n'est pas le
fait d'une seule personne le seul
établissement
vrai ou faux la poutine est un mets
traditionnel du québec
ou faut-il être un peu plus précis
réponse mais traditionnelle du québec
ok je vous la corde c'est une question
facile je voulais vous la donner 20 1 1
font là dans votre assiette de 20.7
agréable un super 20 points vers ça fait
un bon départ c'est ça les autres qui
sont maîtres beaucoup plaisir c'est que
celle là sera bien très bien alors on
roule vers notre invité après la grosse
boule on va vers notre invité qui se
trouve à paris on ne recule devant
aucune dépense s'élève cette première
classe notre invité c'est monsieur erwan
caradec qui êtes bancaire quel
arrondissement présentement à paris dans
le 2ème arrondissement quartier
montorgueil juste à côté des halles je
regarde l'image derrière vous ça me fait
penser à une app
quand place sur la table 5 - tout à fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on a quand la
voulait en fait on avait pu reprendre un
petit peu les codes de steiner est un
petit peu de cette nappe à carreaux et
aussi de la chemise à carreaux kanak est
pardon pour le cliché c'est bien mais tu
es la table continuer vous êtes un
spécialiste de la poutine
on peut dire ça vous êtes le docteur
poutine le docteur tina début de mes
études de médecine sur la sur la poutine
parce que j'y vais donc je suis l'un des
créateurs de la maison de la clape ou
tina à paris et on est le premier
instant exclusivement de 2 tout in sur
paris et du coup moi j'ai vécu pendant
cinq ans à montréal au québec et ça m'a
vraiment marqué c'est quelque chose qui
m'a rappelé ma démarche et
professionnellement comme
personnellement et c'était une belle
façon pour moi de faire honneur à cette
période là c'est de mettre en avant un
beau produit du québec
écoutez on va vous faire un art
également on a été capté vous voyez des
images au restera vous avez pas vu notre
espion il est passé cette semaine et on
a capté sa sur le vph vidéo numéro 2 c
on va montrer votre restaurant en images
donner une idée à quoi ça ressemble on
va retrouver donc l'anah traditionnel et
bien sûr ça c'est votre site web d'abord
c'est joli ans et aux couleurs de la
poutine c'est jaune c'est bleu et vous
avez combien de poutine on voit que la
poutine tabarnak
c'est très polis oui j'ai oublié alors
la couleur dont deux sont exclusivement
végétarienne et sur ces 9 août in on en
avons une des végétariens qui changent
en fonction de la saison c'est à dire
qu'on l'a fait ou légumes de saison et
une autre événementiel qu'on fait
changer tous les trois semaines tous les
mois en fonction de notre humeur du
temps des produits qui sont à
disposition ils ont lalalalala tabarnak
qui a été qui a été nommé comme ça par
mon fils de saipan la chine justement au
restaurant quand on a fait les tests
début et qui m'a regardé qui n'étaient
pas pas c'est ça ta baraque et du coup
on a gardé le même stade
voilà ce qui manque dans ton camp je
suis un peu en colère j'ai gardé
certains codes
québécois par ailleurs pour essayer de
typer certains mots français qui gagnent
facilement dans notre langage quand on a
un petit garçon un chine
je suis content d utiliser le mot skippé
quitterait france a d'ailleurs comme ce
qui peut alors écoutez alice oui les
ingrédients de la poutine
on peut résumer il y en a 3 je pense je
crois qu'il ya du fromage il ya cette
petite sauce brune et puis il ya des
patates
voilà prêt et pat a fait 3-1 crédit cds
tracé la classique avec fait je connais
des restaurants ici à montréal il ya des
tonnes des possibilités de séchage ça
change les patates pour patate douce le
type des fromages hommage au quai en
fête la sauce c'est toujours la même
mais il y ajoute des différences et des
siens pour élever un peu plus le goût
oui absolument
c'est vraiment un spécialement l'argent
devait beaucoup vous voudrez on va lui
demander à lui où il trouve ces
ingrédients et roanne alors moi je me
fournis directement à engis qui est le
grand à leur agissent qu'on appelle
arrivé chez vous on vérifie on vérifie
nous ont dit d'aller marquer oui bon
c'est un classique ça et j'ai perdu je
suis de mon on parlait des ingrédients
je me fournis aux mines de risquer une
grande halle dans lequel tous les
restaurateurs s'approvisionne et on
travaille exclusivement avec des
produits frais le plus possible locales
et j'essaie je sélectionne de façon
assez exigeante que les français pensent
généralement de la poutine est ce que
c'est vraiment une question mais de la
population voilà alors en fait c'est
très surpris du fait qu'on mette de la
sauce sur des frites
parce que c'est pas quelque chose qui
est très inquiet très calmement et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ces trois
produits qui parle énormément en
français c'est à dire que la frite les
français la connaissent et là bien le
fromage de la même façon et le grévy
asos qui est quand même qui est quand
même un jus de viande finalement et qui
est proche de l'accusé traditionnelle
française de ski
on la voulait aller chercher c'est ce
moment de réconfort par exemple quand on
des souvenirs d'enfants qu'on peut avoir
ou moi quand alain faisait le poulet
rôti du dimanche avec les frites le
meilleur moment c'est quand je verser le
jus de mon poulet sur mes frites et donc
on est reparti sur ces codes là de
manière à la prompte à l'adapter au pas
les français
vous parliez tantôt des différentes
variétés de poutine donc au delà de la
poutine tabarnak
il ya la poutine événementielle qui m'a
mois touché qui m'a marqué est-ce que
vous pouvez m'en dire un peu plus c'est
quoi la poutine événementiel alors la
comptine événementielle en fait il est
l'événement il est dans le fait que
c'est qu'elle éphémère en fait nous on
travaille une recette de tout in la
seule limite qu'on a mis c'est ma
créativité et et et cette créativité
elle est maîtrisée par une haute
technicité purement de cuisine parce que
je suis cuisinier de formation j'ai
travaillé pendant 25 ans dans les
cuisines traditionnelles
je suis la chance de ça répare pour
normand laprise à montréal leméac aussi
fidèlement chef haussier en france qui
visualise ça un petit peu comme une
pizza
c'est à dire que on a une base qui est
toujours là même qui est la fritz le
fromage et la sauce et ensuite on
rajoute des garnitures sur le sur le
dessus et on peut mettre des garnitures
relativement simples et peu dispendieuse
comme du lard de l'oignon les choses
comme ça mais on peut aller aussi
chercher des beaux produits
mais par exemple poutine événementielle
de la delà du temps du temps des fêtes
qu'on avait appelé la papa noël était
une revisite delà de l'atteinte farci
aux marrons avec une escalope de foie
gras poêlé par dessus qui était mon
petit hommage à martin picard et sa
poutine au foie gras
écoutez on va aller sur on va continuer
notre aventure sur le web ensemble nous
sommes des enfants du web vous le savez
et nous allons vers notre vidéo numéro 3
à voir les commentaires de vos clients
très récemment yvon sur votre page
facebook il commente votre créativité
culinaire et pas toujours en des fois
ils vont avec des commentaires un peu
assassin je trouve là mais ce parce que
les clients ils ont toujours tort le
sait
on va regarder la vidéo de m3 peut-être
que ce sera difficile à lire comme ça à
2000 km de distance
mais on va en vain salah plateau oui pas
de problème
très bien alors c'est quelqu'un qui
s'appelle armina aminata diallo le
breton dont tu as donc et vous
connaissez et il doit tout il parlait du
cheddar qui étaient coupées en cubes
il dit que c'est du vrai fromage en
grains utilisé au québec sur les
poutines de traditionnel il dit votre
sauce brune
moi je dis que c'est une sauce sucrée
voilà puis il rend je veux casser il
nous ne sommes plus au xviiie siècle dit
il nous avons évolué notre culture
mérite le respect culinaire culinaire
que les français se doivent de lui
accorder
ps j'ai adoré la poubelle électrique je
sais pas ce que ça va alors que vous ne
pouvez l'électricté vous avez mis le
doigt sur un type de commentaires qui me
touche
étant donné que étant donné que j'essaye
d'y mettre un maximum de sincérité et
que comme je dis souvent je préfère
avoir des compléments de des compliments
de gens de chez vous du québec qui
disent qu'on est bien plutôt que d'avoir
beaucoup de gens dans mon restaurant
mais on peut pas plaire à tout le monde
et la même façon que la tradition de la
de la poutine
elle est d'avoir chacun sa petite
recette secrète et j'ai un couple de
québécois kevin ya pas longtemps et lui
était a été un père noël était ravie
mais lui pas du type à bastille elle m'a
dit que les coûts pas parce que c'est
comme chez nous c'est à dire que moi je
mange ma poutine dans une place et lui
va dans une ou deux places dès que de
grévy de recettes de choses comme ça
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
ancré dans la cuisine et qui même ancré
dans la cuisine au niveau du monde là
tous une grand mère qui a une recette
secrète qu'on a mis de côté moi je suis
cuisinier professionnel j'ai une recette
de crêpes qui est la recette de ma
grand-mère et que je n'ai jamais modifié
donc il ya vraiment ce côté où moi je
considère je peux pas peur à tous 1 mais
je suis dans la sincérité c'est à dire
que
personne là quand elle bien là la tante
elle vient on lui pose des questions le
lancia l'a aimée et si elle n'a pas aimé
on peut pas lui en vouloir de ne pas
avoir à aimer ma ce que parce qu'on sait
tous les goûts ce doit peut-être dans la
nature mais quand j'ai des réflexions
constructives qui sont pas forcément dus
sur le fait de comparer une poutine ou
pas comparer une poutine il va s'en
prendre en compte au début par exemple
on disait qu'on mangerait vie était trop
liquide et pendant une semaine une
semaine et demie j'ai tenu mon truc là
on n'est pas trop liquide non vraie vie
et puis un moment donné ben dis bon ben
tu en métal sur métal
sa cote est de 3 en question et j'ai
retravaillé la texture gomme on voit
vite et on l'a fait évoluer et plus et
correctement ça c'est lé plaisir de
pouvoir cuisiner de travailler des
produits de les transformer on les
maîtrise entièrement mais moi il était
hors de question de recevoir des cannes
de saint-hubert et d'importer du fromage
directement du québec parce que j'ai
appris des choses au québec je suis apte
à respecter la planète
et aujourd'hui quand je quand je mets
pommes de terre pousse à moins de 30 km
de paris c'est un choix fromage vient de
deux savoie avec des vaches que j'ai vu
courir dans les prix facturés
directement et mon baby est fait à base
de morceaux de viande ont fait un jus de
viande des échalotes
on y met de la technicité de l'amour ont
fait une sauce barbecue maison et
ensuite on laisse cuire pendant six
heures et des fois juste un degré de
différence va concentrer plus ou moins
asos ou quoi que ce soit ces décolletés
technique donc du coup on fait de la
cuisine on fait de la cuisine et la
cuisine quand vous faites enfin vous
avez quinze personnes à table
forcément un qui va moins apprécié
dernière question à l'iss pour notre
invité non fondées j'allais poser la
question par rapport à la sauce parce
que la personne semble de très très
critique par rapport à la différence de
goût entre la sauce faite à la française
la french touch
et la sauce québécoise est ce qu'il
serait qu'en possible je sais pas moi
d'importer de la sauce du québec venant
il l'a dit justement annoncé interdite
alors en fait les grèves im mois pour
avoir toutes les deux beaucoup
restaurant à poutine je suis allé chez
les cruise joue c'est 'je suis là je
suis allé chez la vente is que je marque
je sais pas trop et du coup il n'y a
aucune source qui a le même goût sûr
face aux industriels
moi je me j'aime beaucoup mes enfants
ils aiment beaucoup la poutine
on s'en va différend récent depuis
parfois c'est particulier de la durée
soir alors ça c'est des ports fou il est
allé au restaurant à paris mais s'en
tire donc faire preuve de créativité
mais oui absolument
en dehors des recettes ils sont
différentes ce qu'on reconnaîtra
toujours c'est la qualité des
ingrédients on sait pas avoir dans quand
on va dans un restaurant on sait quand
la pâte de pommes de terre elle est
plutôt bon elle est écrite de façon un
peu tordue on le sait on le sent tout de
suite
l'huile al'avantage de nous offrir des
ingrédients qui sont naturels qui sont
de la poutine à paris j'y tiens
importante pour nous aussi c'est que
l'école de façon de se nourrir à paris
ont beaucoup changé ces lacs avant on
avait une cuisine traditionnelle
on les gens aller dans certains types de
restaurants aujourd'hui c'est en train
de changer il ya beaucoup plus de
restaurants fast-food qui s'ouvre à
pareil que de petits bistrots sympas de
quartier ou quoi que ce soit et les fast
food qui vaut aujourd'hui ont une
certaine cible et il le ramène une
certaine philosophie de la cuisine qui
est totalement l' inverse de la lienne
on se nourrit pas pour se nourrir on se
nourrit pour être bien pour nourrir sa
machine mais c'est un tout et
aujourd'hui nous on contrôle notre part
on est très attentif sur le taux de sel
dans nos plats sur le gr oupe livre
utilise que des produits sains des
produits frais moi par exemple j'ai un
micro réflexion à faire sur la poutine
c'est que je la trouve très corsé très
salée sur la sauce st-hubert là ce
scanner on assiste là côté industriel
derrière
ouais je sais que si vous
si vous avez l'occasion est ravie de
recevoir le goûter notre notre sauce
sassou petit goût de doha gouttes de
sauce de ragoût de boulettes qu'on peut
avoir deux choses comme ça c'est mijoter
mitonné arrêté arrêté parce que là vous
devez faire il est bientôt midi
solutions saas et les ballerines de ce
côté ici écoutez erwan vous donner
l'adresse de votre établissement
parce qu'il faut payer pas tout le monde
qu'est l'internet saléen sûr il ya des
gens qui cote en ce moment ils ont pas
l'internet alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
donc alors on pourrait le retrouver donc
la maison de la poutine au 11 rue mandar
à paris dans le 2ème dans le quartier
montorgueil qui est un très beau
quartier piétonnier et une belle balade
après avoir manger une poutine c'est
très très agréable où l'on n'hésite pas
à venir vous voir vraiment ça nous fait
très plaisir
vous êtes ouvert depuis février ou
janvier dernier s'est tout récemment
voilà et on va on va ouvrir d'autres
restaurants dans paris parce qu'on croit
énormément aux produits et que on a un
très bon retour et qu'on est très fière
de mettre son produit en avant est
fantastique alors erwan ce fut un
plaisir de vous accueillir à notre table
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup stéphane à la prochaine
merci beaucoup
alors c'était erwan caradec à paris qui
a vécu au canada co fondateur de la
maison de la poutine
il pourrait être président de la russie
éventuellement c'est comme il s'exprime
je trouve qu'il pourrait remplacer cette
laïque août
s'ils trouvent un sma cette vieille
croûte que je parle de routine la
poutine évidemment la déroute de poutine
voilà c'est mona qui est bien dit et ce
serait un bon titre de recettes ça la
poutine à la croûte tellement drôle lui
un train est parti avec des robes assez
on va arrêter de rials c'est le jeu de
la boule deuxième jeu de l'émission on
ferme les lumières parce qu'on aime ça
c'est plus sexy par ces pratiques
intimes notre affaire alors écoutez
avant de parler de recettes de cuisine
ensemble 10 voici la question aussi
leonardo vous pouvez participer en fin
de compte si vous n'avez pas la réponse
vrai ou faux
ça se complique à négocier question se
durcit ciel
c'est pile ou face comme la croûte lavée
iq routes alors vrai ou faux la poutine
peut conduire un état de dépendance
psychologique ou physiologiques tels une
drogue
la poutine vrai ou faux peut conduire un
état de dépendance psychologique ou
physiologiques tels une drogue
moi c'est faux c'est vrai c'est vrai
ouais pourquoi alors vous allez vous
accorder 30 points
voilà il n'y a aucune raison pour
qu'elle les mêmes raisons que la la la
la
les labels et des burgers de certaines
marques là on vais y retourner
on sait pas pourquoi mais on veut
retourner la question de goût personnel
ça dépend de chaque personnage choix
individuels comme le cannabis
voici il ya une enquête qui est des
faits là dessus une étude sérieuse
scientifique
oui en général sont scientifiques sinon
on en paye pas il appert que les
triglycérides ceux des affaires qui
couvrent par grace contenus dans la
poutine agirait dans notre cerveau
directement sur le circuit de la
récompense comme la cocaïne qui tous
impliqués dans la dépendance à l'alcool
alors il parait ces scientifiques une
recherche faite au canada on a les
résultats sont deux pages de tam-tam
cette semaine où vous consultez les
articles on en a cinq
il y en a un qui vous parle de ça on dit
que les triglycérides de la poutine
pourrait agir comme des drogues dures
dans le cerveau pas titres à 12 comme le
pote de cannabis non c'est plus grave
que ça oui comme d'agrès croûte dure et
on parle ici du système de récompenses
qui est complètement rassasié par ces
triglycérides et pourra donc entraîner
des comportements de dépendance une
histoire à suivre bien sûr il faudrait
que la poutine est à consommer avec
modération
la génération ça n'est pas notre point
de vue quand je serai à la retraite on
vous dit ça ne pourra pas du tout la
bombe sale aliments qui a pas que ça et
c'est même l'alcool qui fait ça c'est
tout ce qui est très bon en bouche n'est
pas forcément bon pour le voir
absolument
pensez vous qu'on pourrait faire de la
poutine avec c'est pas en a aucun mot ne
faisait pas vraiment de pommes de terre
beaucoup on en a beaucoup et attention
chez moi à l'ouest et les bamilékés on a
beaucoup de pommes de terre la pomme de
terre mais la pomme de terre que nous
avons ici il qui est très très
savoureuse d'ailleurs très très bonne
c'est pas de plusieurs façons non non ça
c'est pas du plantain attention donc la
pomme de terre chez nous se mange de
plusieurs façons on a on peut en faire
un ragoût un ragoût de pommes de terre
on peut en faire en forme de frites et
même dû piler dont le piler chez nous ça
se fait avec du haricot rouge noir et
c'est vraiment vraiment très très aimé
des enfants
j'ai habité 10 ans est un enfant en
afrique et je me souviens d'avoir mangé
dépens de terre africaine
on les a portés de perrelet non vous
n'avez pas ses jeunes ouailles à houndé
tu voyais à oui je conseille au liberia
voix il ya plein de pommes de terre
c'est la civilisation et vous savez le
cameroun est considérée comme le grenier
de la sous région afrique centrale dont
la plupart de nos voisins viennent se
ravitailler chez nous en toutes sortes
de choses vous êtes arrivé ici à quoi
plusieurs années je suis arrivé là il ya
bientôt 8 ans bientôt
oui je suis arrivé en 2010
connaissez-vous alors la poutine avant
d'arriver ici non malgré que je mangeais
les pommes de terre tous les jours chez
moi je connaissais pas la poutine les
est ici que je les découvre c'est pas
une honte parce qu'en 1957 pratiquement
personne ne le connaissait ça a été
inventé en 1957 973
je dis si anodine elle à se mettre
d'accord avec notre service de recherche
il ya qu une seule personne de vie pour
la poutine
cinquante ans de vie 51 ans 2,5 j'ai dit
plus de 50 ans une année on est allé en
vacances à l'argentine avec ma famille
puis mes enfants et voulait faire
connaître la poutine notre famille en
argentine
alors on a porté les petit sac avec la
poudre la poudre la poudre blanche
cocaïne au nom selon l'ex-régie puis on
essayait de faire la même chose là bord
mais les fromages sait pas exactement
les mêmes temps normal alors sa santé
une espèce de puer mais les goûts
étaient pas mal et votre famille la
bien-aimée où il met janvier mais ça
alors il part du fromage évidemment je
dis évidemment parce que je suis je
connais l'histoire mais vous la
connaissez également le cheddar
c'est à dire de celle fromage en grains
du québec s'est fait avec du lait cru
mais après ça j'ai aucun autre détail
sur la fabrication du pain on n'est pas
des fromages ici nom il paraît assez
particulier au québec d'utilisation de
ce fromage qui fait des reins qui
devient un peu comme du lait caillé
cahiers mais un peu plus arrondies un
peu plus mou un peu plus bondissant
comme gumby voilà est maintenant passé
des explications scientifiques nous
sommes maintenant prête pour notre
troisième et dernière question dans
notre jeu de la cause bull qui vaut pour
50 points vous avez pour le moment 20
points un point les autres entrants ils
attendent tous les deux 20 points une
autre question vrai ou faux si vous
répondez différemment peut-être que vous
serez la gagnante
on croise les doigts répondez pas de la
même façon parce que là ils vont va être
sûr d'avoir une paire tente alors une
perdante
un père dans ses préjugés subconscient
vous prédite d'une certaine joue à vous
expliquer ce passage est une machine à
remonter le temps et je remonte dans le
temps je veux pas par la manière et je
sais déjà que la france organise
aujourd'hui que vous allez perdre les
dés sont joués
moi je peux bon est-ce que vous tenez je
vous pose la question quand même allé
s'imposer à les islamistes je vais pas
perdre
max est sûr de gagner annie écoutez je
suis pas une perdante
ça coûte cher d'électricité on y va sa
porte sur le fromage le troisième
question 50 points l'utilisation du
fromage en grains dans les poutine est
essentiellement un phénomène québécois
en raison de la grande production
fromages de chez air du québec
voici la question dans les autres
provinces canadiennes quand fromage
cheddar n'est pas disponible
il est remplacé de préférence par du
fromage feta ou du gruyère vrai ou faux
faites un feta ou non est ce qu'elle est
remplacée par du fil depuis hier ou du
greffe au faux vrais deux réponses
différentes
et la réponse est un faux vous êtes
perdant olala est bon bon c'est fait
c'est de la bouffe ça passe et puis
après on oublie pas fait que je vois
quand une chose j'ai envie d'aller
écouter on va mais dans quelques minutes
ce sera possible
vous avez 20 minutes avant la prochaine
émission oui mais je pense pas qu'on va
peut-être après l'émission en guyane
malaisie tout de suite merci pour cette
semaine c'est fini c'est terminé
si vous regardez n'ont pas parlé de
spécialités camerounaise banon s'est
posé la question je lis la poutine avait
que des pommes de terre des pommes de
terre au cameroun sinon cameroun il ya
plein d'autres choses qu'on peut manger
comme jean dollé
d'une daube à du poisson braisé du
pilipili aux pommes de terre il ya
toutes sortes de choses donc il ya ce
qu'est de la poutine
non il n'ya pas de la poutine il ya dû
piler de pommes de terre avec des
haricots rouges ou noirs est-ce que vous
pouvez le faire ici bien sûr pour la
prochaine vous apporter ce sera super on
doit excellente idée léo merci ce sera
une façon pour moi de vendre nos
spécialités africaines
ce sera à l'émission de la semaine
prochaine c'est ça ouais d'accord
déplacement prochain
on vous a déjà décidé les way la semaine
risque d'être malade j'ai traîné
digestion je veux pas de cookies allons
parler de la mosaïque culinaire
africains nous camerounaise de récupérer
tous ses maux merci à lui chantal tandem
ce fut un véritable plaisir avec plaisir
partagé à la semaine prochaine à la
presse et à la semaine prochaine oui je
l'espère je me souhaite du si vous le
pouvez vous venez oui mais sinon par
l'accusant duchaussoy et 0 à la
prochaine vers la prochaine
et puis à la télévision quelques
miracles ont fait le salut la lah à la
semaine prochaine à la semaine prochaine
au revoir